okay when we last left you at the good
place tell me what can you cheese's with
coming up to well I mean we're about to
shoot season four so that's happening
and that's off and I will be murdered by
Mike sure if I give too much away but
you've met some of the people in the
finale of season three that will be
carrying on with us and there's a lot
that's about to happen between Eleanor
and Chitti and that's all I can say
otherwise I will be killed and I love
you but you're just not worth it and it
has grown into really I mean it's a
whole thing
yes and I think the first season there
was some nerves that it might not get
picked up people stuck with it
well that's because I think there's also
like a weird there was a weird prejudice
against it because it was high concept
and I think people think that the
American public or the public around the
world can't handle high-score high
concept on network and that's a terrible
and stupid prejudice because actually
they got it and they loved it and it
translated around the world and and we
need to not underestimate the people who
can get high concept and it's so cool to
see it becomes such a lobster I think
Netflix was a huge part of helping that
as well the push that you get when that
like reaches everyone else but we have
such a dedicated and intelligent and
funny fanbase and it's just become this
weird cult thing that I didn't ever see
coming and I didn't get fired oh my god
I was so scared that I was gonna get
fired that I ate everything I could find
just to try and get my money's worth I
gained like 11 pounds which is fantastic
but I burst out of all of my costumes so
they had to leave everything open at the
back so I wore every dress that you see
is to Hani for the final couple of
episodes of season one as an apron just
because I was sort of stress eating and
also just trying to make sure that I got
everything I could before they
inevitably fired me but they didn't so
that's nice okay you brought up your
activism yeah you you are so outspoken
what I love I'm wild you are wild so
what kind I mean first of all what's
your what's your pissed off mode I mean
who are you pissed off back now anybody
no no no currently they've been behaving
themselves I am I am just pissed off
generally with celebrities and
influences and I've started a petition
on social media we have almost 150,000
signatures already in under a week to
stop celebrities and influences from
being ill are allowed to sell diet
products to their fans because it's so
grossly irresponsible it's such a misuse
of privilege and you're selling like
laxatives and really unhealthy powders
that you buy over the internet - very
young and impressionable people so I'm
trying to get those banned from social
media I'm on a mission and I mean okay I
was reading you know you refuse to get
airbrush because we're becoming immune
to like humanity and to flaws and we're
comparing ourselves to AI images and
digitally enhanced images and so
therefore how can you ever look at a
digitalized photograph of yourself and
then be satisfied with what you see in
the mirror like it's not just bad for
young people who follow you it's bad for
you when I see myself airbrushed I see
myself thinned out and made lighter with
a straighter nose and a thinner face and
flawless note poreless skin and then
that that inevitably makes me
dissatisfied with what I see in the
mirror it's bad for us and I think it is
truly designed to make us want cosmetic
surgery in order to match what we see on
the app and cosmetic surgeons are now
coming out talking about the fact
they've got so many young people walking
in asking them to look like they're
filtered selfies so this is like we're
at a crisis point and eating disorders
and cosmetic surgery and teens and
self-harm and suicide are the highest
they've ever been there's no way there
isn't some sort of correlation with all
of these different things these apps the
social media if you use badly and bad
bad influences I'm gonna find you I must
stop you from anybody not really
backlash I think sometimes I make little
mistakes and people educate me
them and I'm not an ego maniac so I'm
willing to learn
most people are in support of me some
people have said that I'm too privileged
to speak out but I think that's a
ridiculous way of looking at things the
point of having privilege is to use it
to help other people otherwise you're
just greedy so I would rather just
ignore those people and keep going and
try and help and know that I can sleep
at night knowing that I'm at least
trying to do something rather than be
complicit in the evil of this industry I
love it yeah I do want to you know miss
the opportunity to talk to you about the
show but that every time I read
something that you say I
it gives me thank you very much thanks
for asking me real questions I really
appreciate it
you